flappers burbank tomorrow night the 10
p.m show still has tickets
so that is um july 15th at flappers in
burbank i'm going to be in salt lake
city utah at wiseguys
july 16th and 17th the tempe improv
um on august 6th and 8th i'm going to be
at caroline's on broadway
august 12th through 14th um and then go
to andyletterman.com for a bunch of
other dates that i'm not going to waste
your time with
hey you guys i am finally coming back on
the road i can't believe it but i'm
coming to
florida all over the place october 12th
i'll be at the improv comedy theater in
tampa florida
and october 13th i'll be at the orlando
improv
and october 14th dania point improv and
dania beach florida i'm really excited
and also we have a new drop this week
for sleepover by esther go to
sleepoverbyaster.com
i am very excited for you to see the
very nice made in la
hand-dyed loungewear also my
picture that i drew that got stolen and
ripped
as a meme everywhere i finally have
taken back the night and
put it on t-shirts you can get them at
[Music]
annieletterman.com
this is actually my first boyfriend i've
lived with period so it's like the first
guy that like
wanted to move with me period so i knew
it was meant to be because no one ever
lived i never lived with anyone
oh my gosh at 32 so my yeah my boyfriend
i mean it was like we started dating the
month before the pandemic so it was like
i was like trying to get him not to move
in he kept bringing like his playstation
like things that were like
plugged in i'm like why is this plugged
in and then i was like the minute the
pandemic
hit i was like if you leave i'll die
like you have to stay and i always tell
them i'm like i don't mean but i'm like
i would have dumped you
i would have broken up with him and it
wasn't like it was in a healthy way
yeah no but i think that's it's almost
like he
was forced to prove himself very fast
and he did and i went beyond
i didn't want to say i love you till the
pandemic was over because i was like
scared it was just like
panda right but then i like couldn't
help it but i was scared for like a week
after we said it i was like
you thought i was like jinx you or
whatever yeah i don't know i just got
like scared i've never been scared of
saying i love you
right away starting with dave like
i had to in my head like the first two
months be like don't say it out loud
don't say it out loud let him
say it first like i had to keep it in
well obviously it's always so awkward
too when you
are feeling the love feelings for
someone because i for me i say i love
you to like the bank teller and stuff so
i'm saying like
i love you to everyone i'm like i love
you i love you and i'm like skipping
over him like you're cool
wait um what is the how did you say why
did you guys say i love you to your
person are you asking her in like in
hebrew what is it
oh you know that you're so much better
i always like say that i was like i just
i love them do you remember when you
guys first exchanged i love yous with
your partners
i don't even know if moses says i love
you he grew up like not saying i love
you to people he doesn't say i love you
but he's very like loving and does so
much for me
so i don't really care i say i love you
all the time i don't even know if he's
ever said
like i'm trying to think if there's i'm
sure he has it he just never says it and
people always call it out on videos dude
like he jefferson
says i love him he never says it back
which it bothered me at first but now
like doesn't it well that might not be
his love language
yeah he does saying he like he doesn't
express it verbally but just like
actions yeah he's super like yeah
everything else
acts as service cuddly touchy like all
that stuff like that but like he just
never says i love you to anyone like his
anything yeah what's yours i really want
acts of service
and i think we all know that i just want
to be like fed
but what do you settle for
availability any time not quality time
just anytime
any time um uh quality time
yeah um which i don't get a lot of
because bobby has a very um
is i think it's called like dismissive
avoidant kind of personality
what is that um it's basically um
exactly how
how it sounds um it's like he has very
few
really deep deep relationships he's in
one with me
but still his he's very incapable of
really like
um showing it in like a sincere way i
can't really explain it
was he enmeshed with his mom was his mom
like overbearing or his dad or something
no but very abusive um childhood so
um yeah problems or feelings are
very like we don't do that you know i
feel like i sense that in him and every
time i see him the way i show him i
respect him is i just like barely speak
to him
like that's his honestly that's the best
thing to do to him like
i try to fix him i'm like bobby let's
sit down you gotta just have a little
more self-confidence
yesterday i was like i asked him if he
wanted me to watch his set and give him
notes and he was like
god no and i was like okay
trish you're really familiar with the
comedy community
that last class podcast is all bleeped
and then out saw you guys podcast like
what was bleeped out i was like oh my
god
that was the funniest [ __ ] i was in
tears when you just
the shock on bobby's face when you were
just like just throwing names out there
was the best thing i've ever heard well
to know about the comedy
community and not like have to work
such an amazing beautiful thing i know
we were like all at home cheering you on
oh my gosh really because i wondered
that when you asked me on and i was like
i know you guys are all connected to it
so i was like i wonder how that is
because you have to be on like good
terms and obviously people probably like
hate me and i like this dumb [ __ ] you
know
we should just bleep out what we say
back to her
if we could like blur out whether we
give a thumbs up or a thumbs down
everything was bleeped last time which
is violent do you remember
like 11 years ago we met twice do you
know this
i wait what we should be doing a
newlywed game with you guys
what is what i didn't even know what
that thing what are you just like ask
questions like dude
yeah she's too young for the new little
world yeah
she was old oh my gosh wait are you
older than me you don't know yeah
really yeah five years
are we the same age yeah oh okay so
we're like literally what is your sign
sign
pisces okay i thought we were like so
similar because when you're saying like
access service and why are you moving
right away i was like oh my god are you
a tourist dude
i thought you were yield that's what i
was getting you
were both from illinois which i just
realized yeah from there too
i didn't know that yeah i'm from like
rockford like northern illinois
i'm from chicago suburbs both wearing
denim oh yeah oh my god we're really on
in sync today
the oldies are wearing sweatpants
what do you remember of meeting me or
should you go first because i don't want
to embarrass myself
okay wait we met twice okay wait no this
does sound so familiar because
we met once definitely at the comedy
store yeah you were with that like
really old guy
you were like the little kid you were
the little kid that went on stage and i
thought you were like actually a child
and i was like why is she in here
oh my god yeah about don barros yeah i'm
so glad she wasn't talking about dave or
something i got like so worried
oh yeah i just remember
and it was like up in the upstairs room
and it was like really really late
i'm not even sure why i was there was i
like in the audience i don't know
how we met you were there
you were there with your mom and i i
don't remember
much like it's very blurry but i just
remember you were there and everyone
loved you and thought you were so fun
and exciting
and i can't remember if i already knew
of you before or if this was like the
first time but you definitely like
seemed very special
and like you and your mom were super fun
but i remember being in the downstairs
room in the original room oh okay so
maybe but that makes sense maybe you
watch it upstairs like you were floating
around
yeah and then the other memory i have
was
this is so random i have such a clear
picture of it but i don't remember where
it was but it was at an audition
i don't know for what yeah way out
somewhere like in
like somewhere way far out in the valley
we were auditioning to play their
mothers
yeah it was definitely like a
super shady audition like off casting
website
yeah like something yeah but i just
remember being like oh that's that girl
again and then i
found you online somehow and started
following you and then that was it no
like
i remember seeing you on crazy
ex-girlfriend i was just like oh my god
like she really crushed it because i
just remember like
i thought you were this little kid and
you were going up there playing this
little kid thing
and i was like why is this little kid
with this old man in the comedy store
like it was just so weird
and i remember you then you put it up on
stage like you were even more like a
little kid and i was just like this is
so
and then i saw he's like oh she's like
on everything like it was really crazy
yeah well i wonder if like i saw you and
just was like oh my god like
pam anderson like all my like blonde
like clean vibes
in one and that's why i like really
stuck yeah you are
very much esther's type
like honestly your hair or your makeup
you're out i'm probably gonna come next
week dressed like you it's gonna be so
weird i'm not gonna quite pull it off
you need my silicone
oh yeah i want to see her oops i started
to feel weird with them and
actually the truth is as soon as i had
them on i woke up from surgery
i hated them i was like oh my god this
was a mistake
because i have sort of like a uh and i
love my body but it is sort of this like
boyish body
and it's always worked out with with a
clothes with a style that i go for
when i got boobs i couldn't i had to
change my whole style to this
type of girl that i just didn't vibe
with
also i started to feel sick i started
having like heart palpitations stuff
like that so i was like
two years in i was like you go was it
cause you were so hot in the mirror
you're like
oh my god wait so yeah did you have the
illness present plant endless like um
well you know how that's like all right
now like anecdotal like i think i did
um but esther saw them yeah i think when
i first met you you had did you grab
them immediately i think i did oh yeah i
pulled you in the bathroom and said can
i see you didn't put me in the bathroom
at
all you you were there was no bathroom
scene you were in public there were
people in the room
and like let me see your boobs yeah you
flash them like all out well esther does
this thing where
she'll flash hers first so hopefully you
do the same but i didn't bite
i think master and i pulled like one of
each test when i
met annie i knew i knew of her so i knew
i was like i'm just gonna pull her shirt
down
oh my god i love that i pulled hers up
she pulled mine down
i love flashing people too but like now
it's like you can't do that like i was
flashing people and they're like no you
can't do that anymore i was like really
like i always think it's so fun but
i guess people 2021 well i feel bad when
i was in high school i used to do it to
people we would like flash people and
then you'd get stuck at a red light
you're
like oh [ __ ] i love it i wish i wish i
wish we could just like fly i mean do
you still do it i mean i wish we could
just still do that
i always did it and then when i started
dating the guy i'm with now he was like
i don't think you should keep doing that
i thought my boobs were like so little
that it was like nah i was like it's
like a polish boy or whatever
there were like guy friends i had where
i would flash them and i'd watch like a
relationship change in like a split
second like they'd be like oh and i was
like oh no
they turn them off yeah no it turned
them on and then it was like so bonery
just gross so funny boobs to me aren't
like super erotic i like looking at them
but they're not like a neurotic thing
that's why i like always didn't mind
flashing them i think they're funny yeah
yeah i think they're funny yeah i think
they're cute i was thinking today on the
ride over that's so weird we're talking
about this like
if you guys like if we were men right
and like born men and we took
our and would you just do not assume
anything of me i know i was like born i
was like i don't know what yeah
um but would you be topless all the time
would you be like
without a shirt no because my nipples
are so sensitive the thought of like the
wind
against them makes me like scared is it
really i
i just feel like you have like hairy
nipples and you know someone don't know
tonight i have super hairy nose no i
have hairy
hairy i have hair in my nipples coarse
ones that i have to walk out sadly
do you really not have that no i mean i
have my nipples are [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie they're like stitch i like it flashy
right now they're stitch they're scars
it's [ __ ] but i've never had hair
there i guess we all have our things so
mine are like started
mine's like literally ones up here and
one's down here for real
why do you have fake boobs yeah i had
fake boobs i had like three lifts
i've gotten three different implants
yeah my boobs were fogged like the first
time i
had my boobs like they were uneven and
one was like d cup one was like a cup
like they were just really uneven
when you were the ones you were born
with yeah they were so one was like
literally a d cup in like middle school
and one was like a b cup so they were
like super and they were really floppy
they pointed down
nipples huge these have the biggest
nipples so i got those cut down like
so now they're just really like messed
up although i still think they're funny
to like flash or whatever but
i've never had the hair but maybe
because i've had implants for so long
maybe
the hair just maybe that's what they
took out the part of the nipple they
took out was the hair growing
i don't have any sensitivity you could
like squeeze them and i could not feel
them yeah
so esther's seen some things happen in
that very chair
we really she re-pierced her nipple in
front of me it was horrible
i had put these hoops in my nipple holes
and some
white stuff came out and she was like oh
and i smelled them and esther was upset
it was actually honestly the best
episode ever
so that's why we gave her a little bell
we gave her a bell if it's too much for
her she rings her belly
i love that too i'm louder than the bell
though so i don't care
since we're veering towards sexual i
have a question you don't have to answer
but
i feel like the way moses looks at you
and treats you
i'm like what is their sex life like
like they
must be so it must be so [ __ ] good
like are you allowed to say yeah yeah
i mean that's nothing bad i love talking
about sex i mean i always it's so funny
no we used to be like banging all the
time but like this is like like i was
telling you it's like my first day
should probably like live with someone
so i feel like the sex goes down way
more not as
i mean we still like do like twice a day
but like when we first went
like quarantine we
i feel like that's not a lot anymore i
feel bad we do it at night before bed
and morning when wake up and i feel like
there should be more spontaneous sex
it's literally like all right yeah
i feel like and then in the morning okay
they're hard to [ __ ] and then that's it
and then i'm like we should probably do
it we should be so spontaneous and
yeah he we used to do it all the time
but i think that comes from like when
you love somebody just know it's there
as opposed to when i didn't live with
him i was like
i was like you want to like get them
with your [ __ ] kind of
yeah yeah you're like it's like for
another thing yeah i want to go
todd and i were talking about i want to
go to um
we want to do like tantra weekends and
different like weird sex
wait what is i know chandrasex but what
is a tantra week they have like weekends
where you go with your person and they
have different like
stuff i mean i don't know are you
looking for a person
with a little bit of a bigger finger
than that i hope yeah your fingers are
so tiny okay so little
they're gonna go and kalila at some
point she's coming with me [ __ ]
those are fingers two times a day
yes is this a lot or a little it's a lot
it's a lot okay
really it's good that's healthy though
yeah we like it has only been a year
it's like super hot still yeah oh my god
well and the thing is too we have like
fun things at our house so we have like
little like wedges and stuff that's like
our favorite thing to stack up because
he's like an architect so he builds
furniture so he's like stacks up these
wedges
so my body will be like in a z so it's
like really fun because we're trying to
have a baby so we're trying to like push
all the like semen down
so i'll be like in a z position so it
can flow down and it's so fun
so it's like a jackhammer he has my legs
like this and it's just like jackhammer
like that but
my head's upside down so it's like a
rush to the head so does he
wake you up or does he wake up before
you and you just hear like him building
he's like building like you're the
building's at nighttime i'll usually
come upstairs from like watching tv and
i'll see like the blocks rearranged and
that's
a different position every night and
then the morning just like sticking it i
love like when guys just stick it in
like while i'm sleeping like we used to
do all the time like in the middle night
like just stick it in like i love
getting woken up by like
i've had to tell my boyfriends that too
i'm like listen you have my consent you
can just bang me when i'm asleep yeah
not to sound like crusty but i don't
it's not that easy to just
slip it in
yeah they shove it in i'm with you shove
it yeah i like to shove it like i like
it when it's just mine is dry as a bone
yeah yeah yeah it gets wet oh my god my
dog hospital's calling me oh hello how
are his balls did you keep them
they've got one and a half balls by the
way like one bit one's normal size
oh my god it's like your boobs
normally when i give people the balls i
put them in a jar of formalins it's
toxic
so would you rather be are you going to
keep them forever if you're going to
keep them forever we should put them
well let me ask
esther what are you i'm giving them to
you so just kidding
um what do you think i should do i think
that keep them in the formal in but
you're going to dispose of them because
just generally it's going to get i'll
probably just show them on the podcast
you can keep them forever in the in the
jar you can why don't you think on it
yeah i'm going to think on it i i can i
think on it we got 20 million for
netflix deal is that true who
oh wow tim who works here i got 20
million dollars for a netflix deal
wow no
i can confirm yeah no you're on my
podcast right
now why are you laughing so hard because
well one you're on my podcast and you
didn't tell me that oh i did you just
didn't hear because you were
talking so much i've never met i've
never met a
person who could chat me out out chat
out chat chat me out oh that did sound
dirty
okay thank you so much can i get your
podcast on spotify
uh no i don't have that deal either
you're just making me sound so poor on
should i give you a thumbs up and a like
yes i would love a thumbs up a like
subscribe
please we can really use it we're
renaming it to randy's balls good
podcast
give you five five star for five all
right thank you thanks dr dean
bye why don't you have a dog
i did have a dog i gave it to my sister
yeah
freaking my ex gave it to me for a vlog
he's like here's a dog and i've never
owned a dog in my life and i lived in a
little apartment
and i was like what how i didn't know
how to take care of him like i just fed
him all through the night because he
kept crying and then he kept pooping and
i yeah it was crazy he said he got him
from like the side of the road from one
of those like
fake breeders you know whatever because
it's like it's a pomeranian then turn
into like this american eskimo or
whatever
we don't have him he comes for
visitations on the weekends i just
cannot take care of animals
i'm like i used to be scared of dogs now
i like love him but my sister
thankfully took him but i remember he
gave him to me and like a video and i
was like i don't
i don't want to take care of that i've
never taken care of dog in my life i
feel like that's the worst
gift that could possibly be a turtle
because turtles live so long
yeah but turtles will outlive you like
you're that's a that's a and you can't
cuddle it
right birds are a real big one birds
because birds are very like
like strawberries like meanest presents
well my
dave my fiance had a bird with his ex so
when you bring up birds i'm just like
disgusting
[Laughter]
i lost custody to his son conyer really
with your ex
his name was rasta yeah and then when my
ex moved to
um texas he named him because he was
panamanian oh
and so he moved to texas he took rosta
and i was heartbroken
because i bought rasta after i won a
thousand dollars
on the slot machine in vegas and i
bonded with him
were you wearing that hat machine
with my cup
but yeah i did lose a parrot too to an
ex breaks my heart everyone
had bobby and a parrot too much it would
be too much
would like be repeating [ __ ] bobby said
behind her back
break your heart do you have animals
here oh yeah
you do why have i never seen them
usually the dogs are everywhere you know
in fact i have so this downstairs area
is um
a place where my fosters live my foster
because i foster dogs a lot and we have
a really big
um dogo argentino in in the next room
she
i will let you know she did pee on the
floor she did yeah
esther
[Music]
so summer's coming and i have to know
are you a dad bod or a six-pack kind of
girl well it really depends if i've
drawn my six pack on or not
because if i don't draw it and i do have
a natural dad i'm a girl with a six-pack
who loves a dad
yes you are you are i'm i'm a dad bod
who loves a dad bod either way
either way our friends at manscaped have
the fellas
hairy bodies covered they just launched
their fourth generation performance
package which includes the lawnmower 4.0
which we all have it in love it
and you heard that right it's the 4.0
even if you're a fan of a bush i still
think that
bush can be groomed properly trimmed and
trimmed up and lined up well kept like
honestly i'd like todd to maybe
trim a nice little a in there for me all
right it's like scarlet letter
yeah a plus another the first a i got
the new performance package 4.0 includes
the new lawnmower 4.0 this trimmer is
sleek and sexy and the fourth generation
trimmer features a cutting-edge
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their advanced skin
safe technology
the lawnmower 4.0 has 7000 rpm motor a
new multi-function on and off switch
that can engage
travel lock and gives you the ability to
turn the
wow a 400k led spotlight i love the
spotlight
and i'm just gonna leave it at that it's
dark down there i need i need light
um and did we mention that this trimmer
is waterproof
in the shower in the wild your man can
shave his junk and everything in between
in the rain when you guys are dancing
naked in the rain
come on ladies the lawnmower 4.0 is the
best trimmer for you
and him gift it to yourself gift it to
him
it works for everybody get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code
trash manscape dot com that's twenty
percent off plus free shipping with the
code trash
manscaped.com it's hot girl summer
and we have to get your man up to par
with manscaped
you know if you watch this podcast
there's a good chance you need our next
sponsor
better help check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday something preventing you
from achieving your goals esther
yes anxiety same for me and depression
and a whole list of other things which
is why better help is
not just something i want it's something
that i need
and betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can connect in a safe and private
online environment it's so convenient
and you can connect in
what is it like 48 hours that's really a
big deal that means that literally
within 48 hours from right now you could
be
communicating with someone that could
help you and really improve your life
you can send a message to your counselor
anytime and you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly
video or phone sessions all without ever
having to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room you can do this all
from your own home which is very
convenient and better help is committed
to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free
to change counselors if needed which is
very important because
sometimes you don't jive anything you
share is confidential and they have
professional
counselors who are specialized in grief
self-esteem depression
anxiety even sleep trauma which we all
have
family conflicts all of it it's a great
affordable option for people who need
help which is
most likely everyone and financial aid
is available we want you guys to start
living a happier life today and as a
listener you'll get
10 off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health
again that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
trash tuesday
so trish um tell me if this is too much
of a question to answer
that we live in the proximity of your ex
oh which is so scary every time you come
here i had moses drop me off and like
just go as fast as you can i don't want
to think we're like cause people thought
i was like stalking it like
i don't care about him but yeah yes but
i mean when i say proximity
proximity right like you're right across
but so like does that like
do you hate coming here i don't hate it
it's just like
i know how he is he still thinks i'm he
called me this year he still thinks i'm
obsessed with him so it's like weird i'm
like engaged and moved on
yeah he like called me he's like call me
it's blank and then he had like a red
heart and i was like oh like i have no
interest i just like blasted him on my
podcast like why would i ever call you
you're the worst so in his head he
thinks i'm still like obsessed with him
it's so weird he tells people like i'll
just call trash and all this will be
over i was like oh like i do not care
so i don't i don't care i just know in
his head he's probably like oh my god
she's so obsessed with me like driving
past my house or something
it is weird because i didn't know
because he used to live a little further
down i didn't know he was like right
here
yeah he must have moved here like after
we broke up or something
after you did tiger belly
right there i had no idea i was like oh
man
do you ever see them i do oh do you say
are you friendly with them
i'm neutral to all my neighbors yeah i'm
very like i never
say hi first i'm not very neighborly
that way in that way i'm never like
hey how's it going my name is so it's
better to be like that yeah yeah yeah i
always [ __ ] that up
neutral is the way to go because you
don't want to invite any type of
relationship so it's kind of like
you know this is me this is my face with
my hat just like this yeah and then i
move on
that's good do you do that for what for
just so you don't want to like because
you don't want to talk to them or you
just don't want them to like ask for
anything or like
yeah there's no sugar over here yeah
it's good to be that way i want to be
that way i'm overly nice but
like just be like don't like hit on me
like what is it like okay so
um this is going to sound really [ __ ]
up but since i moved in this
neighborhood it's a lot more like
affluent i don't feel a connection to
the people around me because they're
older
they're i don't know is that why you're
dressing like them
it's like i'm my own gardener this is my
gardening attire
um i um but i felt more neighborly when
i was like living in the hood
yeah because you know like nobody cares
there like you can
light up firecrackers no one complains
about your dog barking over here
everything's a problem
yeah really so this is why like i'm very
like ugh i [ __ ] hate my neighbors
because it's like
every tiny thing you have a box outside
your door that's been there for more
than
eight hours please collect it or if you
don't get your trash
bins up your driveway the same hour that
it gets collected
you'll get a text from a neighbor wait
i'm actually jealous i feel like i need
that kind of like
structure we can do we can do a home
switch please
coach your neighborhood's not like that
well you live in a i think a hipper
neighborhood yeah your neighbors
i do but my poor neighbor that was too
nice to me
she's like a high level agent at icm and
every time there's like something wrong
in the neighborhood i'm like is
everything okay like when there's an
earthquake i text her
and she's so nice to me and i just feel
so bad i've like totally abused the
relationship
are you friends with her you just text
her when there's a problem just when
there's a trauma bond
you can get the ring app it'll tell you
when like things happen do you have that
like
i'll tell you like things in your
neighborhood yeah but they like they'll
be like there's a helicopter does anyone
know what happened it's like the same
thing and i'm like
it's like a suspicious person yeah right
yeah i don't want it's always there's so
many dumpster fires i'm like
i'm so flattered i noticed thank you
you guys should do a swap while you guys
should swap with each other's boyfriends
like a wife swap remember that show
where you would like swap that'd be such
a good i don't even
know because dave would fall in love
with kawaii and he would never leave
and bobby would be banging to get away
from him dave would be able to
sleep in right yeah um what else would
he what perks but then you know what
i think that there are perks about you
too that you might be able to offer
bobby
what nice little tits
no i think that you know how you like to
be at all do you like to be
a separate separate room in a way he
would love that we would just sit
silently and otherwise
we'd actually be very happily married
how would you get popcorn though
i can't imagine bobby making popcorn and
bringing it that's the easiest thing to
make if all he had to do was do popcorn
he would choose
um towards me yeah or his he's acts of
service i think his love language is oh
okay so he would go and do stuff make
popcorn
oh no that's he would want acts of
service for me well do you think that's
from asian mother
no that's because of he had an asian
mother i don't [ __ ] know
i don't know who you know i love his mom
but i don't think that's who he raised
who raised him because she's a lovely
lady and i just i refuse to believe this
she's in charge she's in charge because
something got wrong
something happened there if you guys got
my boyfriend you
you're i mean your guys would be so
upset with what
the demands that you would have after
having my sweetheart
todd i have just like an angel
oh really he just does he's just he is
my asian mother like he does everything
for me he's such a sweet sweet sweet man
that's so cool so you guys are you guys
like opposites in that sense are you
more like because you're like the artist
the creative the like
star and what does he do anything
creatively he's an editor but he's very
talented he's got a very good eye and
he's right
he's become very successful over the
pandemic and
he but he knows like he is totally okay
with like sitting back letting me do my
thing but he can help me with it like
it's just
it's really perfect i just can't even
believe it it's so weird i want to ask
you guys something
um what are your thoughts on that kid um
ollie london
um the kid who so he's a he's a white
guy
i'm not sure if he's a youtuber i don't
know what he does but he's an influencer
right
but he i think he paid about 150
thousand dollars in like cosmetic
surgery and now he claims to be korean
i am jealous he did it before me i mean
so he's
he's transracial like what rachel
dolezal claims to be
but he got actual surgery yeah see
that's him now he looked like
the cult he looks like kesha he's like
yeah he looks
whiter than ever oh yeah so why what are
the rules with this
are you is this allowed i don't know i
honestly don't know
because have you watched a rachel
dolezal documentary yeah
her kids were like please mom's top the
pronouns are there but he's using core
and ian with a slash in between as if
it's a separate type of like transracial
pronoun
oh yeah so he's being his own thing wait
can you be transracial is that a real
thing
well he's claiming you know like the
rachel dolezals
claim that like there's a there's a
white guy in florida who also claims to
be filipino
um but his excuse was he was raised by
them and it was such a
that's a community he was surrounded by
so it makes sense him on the other hand
just has a fascination and an obsession
for bts
um okay okay i feel like that's just my
culture that's my home country
that's exactly how i look now um
and i also identify as jimmy and that's
my career name but uh
not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimin or
korean but um
this is something that you guys know if
you've followed my journey for the last
eight years i've really struggled with
identity issues
with who i am i have a probably
unpopular opinion
i probably agree with you on the popular
position i feel like i do too
you're fine with it i like i think you
it
but i'm also not it's not my place to
say it's okay because i'm not korean
but i also i'm like can't we just it's
not
it's not bad right it's not evil or
hateful i just feel like it just
i just honestly feel like it's not my
business to tell someone what they can
like be or want to be and it's like if
he's willing to do all this stuff i
think maybe it's offensive to like
i just don't i just don't i don't we
care i don't mean it in like a shitty
way but it's like it's just so nice i
need to call it korean
in korea i feel like i kind of it's so
interesting because i feel like i'm kind
of i kind of get the same hate as this
but
but it's interesting so like i'm
currently in conversion classes so like
you can convert to being a religion so
it's kind of like the same thing
although i get hate for that like it's
totally normal and like i'm going
through a rabbi and stuff like that to
convert and
then i'll be jewish and then it's
totally cool people are they people get
so mad at me whenever i do
try and like speak hebrew or if i wear
like a high or like starting people get
this like they get so like just because
you're dating because i've always dated
jewish men i just
and because i'm similar to that like i
just like the culture and i don't have
culture so like
i like it and then i don't know i i
don't know but people find it offensive
they find everything offensive i don't
know yeah
i just feel like that is true everyone's
like finding everything offensive anyway
kind of not i mean he is out there like
showing this as so like
wanting it to be other people's business
i guess yeah well kyle you're asian
where are you at i can't speak for the
korean people but
when i how i felt about the white guy in
florida who was filipino
um i i'm more like
you know welcome yeah it was more like
i i guess but also like
i don't know i don't know actually where
i stand on this i'm really
but here's where this is why i there's a
part of me that sort of
feels for him um because when i was in
high school i was
a straight up chola you know i had such
an identity crisis
because of coming from a different
country and then like kind of sort of
being rejected by the filipinos that
were already here because i was a
fob like fresh off the boat but latinos
they took me in like their own they're
like oh we don't care
you know you look ish you know yeah ish
yeah come to our quinceaneras like that
was it was full acceptance and i
really really like leaned into that like
i speak spanish
you know i have i i know every single
spanish musician or max you know like
it's like i'm a complete package i'm a
complete
like latinx package yeah yeah but but
but i would never reject the fact that
you're i am filipino yeah my mom is
filipina but
i think i think jewish is a is an
interesting one like going back to what
you were saying sorry did i cut you off
no no no you didn't oh do we do that i
apologize when we cut off i owe you guys
a lot of apologies
oh you better
wow um the jewish thing is really tricky
because
i dealt with this growing up because i'm
half so my dad is completely jewish my
mom is not at all she's finnish and
like christian or whatever and i always
felt like
the jewish people would say well you're
not really jewish your mom wasn't jewish
but then the
regular the non-jewish people would say
well you're jewish like you're not
christian how you're jewish and so i
always felt like no one accepted me and
then i like as like when i became an
adult i just like sort of decided
i'm if i'm jew i'm jewish like leave me
alone like
i'm it shows up on my 23 and me which is
also weird it's like you can convert
but also it's on 23andme like what is
who's more jewish me or you like i don't
know you're right i'm just surprised
you are because yeah because i like
converted yeah yeah
because the mom has to be jewish like if
you want to enroll your kid in the
hebrew school like the mom has to be
jewish
the one like we know someone like
enrolling their kid in hebrew school and
their mom has to be judged so that's why
i'm like i'm converting so i could be
jewish
because it is so i've learned that too
like the mom has to be the jewish to
consider yourself jew i don't know
yeah my dad's side's my jewish side too
so it's not oh really on my like 23andme
i'm like 20
ashkenazi but we were brought up quaker
our whole neighborhood was jewish
we were not everyone was like when we
had our big 13th birthday party they're
like
nice try not about mitzvah my god
my gut on this is that it feels wrong
but he's not okay here's the thing he
was pretending he was born
like if he was pretending he was born
korean and trying to just like play it
off
i think that would be like because
that's what rachel dolezal did right she
was
she was like getting tanned she was
getting her hair uh permed and doing
other stuff
and she never said i was like i was i
was born white or whatever
and i think that was like the big insult
to people right
less than her being like i identify as
like which i think people still have a
problem with well to take on
like you're not just taking on a look
you're taking on a full history of
people that are
a minority so you do have to consider
that
like what a privilege now you as a white
man to be like
oh yeah it's fun for me to play dress up
in somebody else's skin
is uh sort of my first instinct in all
of this where it's like
dude koreans you know korean americans
and stuff like that it's
you're still a minority you don't know
what that feels like growing up
feeling different not in l.a i mean but
in like let's say
you're um my friend nathan he was a
korean kid growing up in the corn fields
of ohio
he had a rough go you know what i mean
so for
i i i'm curious to see what he feels
about a guy like this
who is like he might feel like maybe
this is a guy in costume
of his in con not taking into
consideration
the difficulty that comes with being
like a young korean american
or you know i can see both sides like
and again i know i'm just
like i'm not korean but i do see part
like how trisha like loves jewish people
i'm like
hell yeah like and she wants to be
jewish like
i think why i don't have a problem with
that even though some people
would say i'm not jewish i identify as
jewish i'm half jewish
yeah i think it's cool when people like
this culture and want to be involved in
it
yeah every guy i've dated has always
said that but then like recently i've
gotten under criticism of people saying
it's fetishizing if you like a certain
like but that's just like the internet
yours doesn't read that way
this reads that way like that yeah also
there the the
jewish religion has a whole like
ceremony they do
they have a whole program set up to
welcome you yeah yeah
but i have a friend who's also who's
interested in converting
really yeah one of my best friends oh i
have a real really who's really good
because i'm kind of like on the
accelerated course because we're getting
married so soon so i'm kind of like on
the speed track
i mean i j i literally just started a
couple weeks ago but there's a lot
like you have to like study everything
like you have to like no and they're
very philosophical when i'm going to is
very like it's more than just like
the like the judaism related all that
stuff like that like the religion to go
with it and like the
dinner is in the religion also there's
like more to it there's like philosophy
behind it and all that stuff like that
so it's like a lot it's like you're
reading that
plus you have to learn because i'm
having about mitzvoth so yeah
wait i'm so excited about it
that's hard work dude yeah it's a lot
well i
like that's why i've been practicing
like on the way here we were practicing
like i literally had my hebrew notebook
i was like practicing my little like
hebrew for the because it's like the
prayers are not only just the prayers
but it's also like the con the tones you
know it's like it's so much so
yeah you guys should come tiffany
haddish recently had a bat mitzvah
is she did you hear her she converted
yeah she was i think
some of her she was adopted by she was
raised she's her mentor i think
yeah okay yeah yeah some some mentored
or raised by a jewish family at some
point and she really identified similar
to you like identify with the culture
deeply yeah yeah yeah
because it is so much deeper now that
i'm like i look again i'm only a few
weeks into it but it is
there is a lot of like philosophy behind
it and stuff and it's like a lot more
than
even i was raised catholic so it's a lot
more than even like christianity and
stuff it's really amazing
it's really just really yeah did you get
confirmed yeah communion confirmation
like
yeah that's i'm really excited well in
israel they're a lot more like
uh like actually kind of lenient they
could they they offered us like a rabbi
that's not a real rabbi to look like a
jewish one bombing i want the real one
you know
i want the whole thing so yeah i don't
know it's really interesting but i know
people have given me criticism about
like only dating jewish guys and being
like fun like
i'm sure everybody does that but people
that are they're just their goal is to
criticize so it doesn't really matter
what you say they're going to like come
up with like yeah
because there is like whatever you want
i like jewish guys
right like is your fiancee jewish yeah
oh okay i guess i'm having a jewish name
oh really like he's he and moses look
alike
they've got the jew look i love that the
hair
so here's the deal i'm going to talk
real with you guys
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch
so when we first heard that mint mobile
offers premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks
a month we're like what's the catch but
after speaking with them and using their
service it all makes sense
because there isn't one mint mobile's
secret sauce is that they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only by cutting out retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs that get
passed down to you
in the form of mystery fees instead min
just passes on the sweet savings
directly to you
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just
15 bucks a month all plans come with
unlimited i said that right unlimited
talk and text and high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network
this is amazing you can use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with all
your existing contacts and if you're not
100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
7-day money-back guarantee
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just
15 bucks a month well i just love when
we have sponsors that actually
save our listeners money and it like
makes sense you know
and this is that's what this product is
george told us he's been using this for
like a year now two years and you
actually save a bunch of money
this is crazy i didn't even know about
it to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com tuesday that's
mint mobile.com tuesday
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
tuesday my dad's going to be so happy
hell yeah
get off that family plan also we're so
psyched because one of our favorite
sponsors you know it's my favorite
sponsor liquid death
finally gave us a promo code so you guys
can go to liquiddeth.com
trash to get a free set of koozies with
your first order of any case of water
or you know always grab some at whole
foods or 7-eleven but go to
liquiddeth.com trash and get a free set
of koozies
we love liquid death i'm not gonna lie
nobody thinks you're lying
this is a more believable thing i've
ever seen in my life drinking fresh
mountain water out of a can
is my lifestyle it really does explain
you
so well
he and so he and i are both
like we identi he's fully jewish he was
raised jewish like kind of bar mitzvah
but we're
very not into the religion oh really at
all like and my dad was neither like i
didn't go to a hebrew school he didn't
want my mom to convert
we're very much like into the culture
and like you know
eat our matzo ball soup but we do not
[ __ ] with the religion at all do you
like the filterfish i don't
i like to filter fish a lot oh am i the
most jewish one in the room
[Laughter]
actually yeah surprisingly i know i mean
look now
six percent ashkenazi i think my twenty
three and me is
oh my god but i'll send it to you guys
screenshot it that's everything so
everyone's a little jewish literally
except for me i've done mine so many
times and i have like none in me
so you have zero zero
[Applause]
was moses raised in it he grew up in
israel he grew up in israel and he was
like raised he had a bum it's fun stuff
but he's not
religious oh he's not did he then did he
have to do the whole israeli army thing
yeah he did yeah right yeah yeah they
both did yeah you're like
it's like a thing you just do like you
just have to you have to but also people
just like watch them like can people say
no
he's like yeah but you're just so like
you're just that's what you do if you
don't go then they look down upon you
in korea too really yeah you have to so
even if you're a celebrity let's say
like you're a member of bts
i i think it's commuted so it's
shortened but you do have to still
serve elvis did it he did yeah yeah he
did it
no and i was like well was it crazy i
was looking back i was like maybe he
looks sort of
like maybe no yeah he went to germany
that's where he met
uh she was 14. that's so crazy because i
love elvis and that makes me really sad
to know that he was like a group well
looking back on all of that you're like
oh
yeah what was the jerry lee lewis 14
year old
cousin why did we i grew up watching
that movie in a really romantic
like lens
randomly like doing their podcast at a
hotel in new york
yeah and he and this other guy was like
come like let's go hang out with train i
thought he meant let's go on the train
like i didn't even understand
and we walked into this hotel bar and
train was there and i was like
train the whole band yeah one guy named
train
one guy no there's a whole band but the
guy is like the yeah
and then we were like hanging out with
them in the bar and then dennis quaid
came over
and they were talking about how they
love to jam and we went up to train's
room
and dennis quidd was like shirtless
playing acoustic guitar
gin and juice we were playing all these
different songs we're all singing
it was cr i saw him at the comments like
do you remember when we like sang the
train he was like
yes and he always randomly meets the
most famous poets
like just it's her stories always have a
combination of never just like
one famous person the oddest combination
of people in a room
but i met train again i was like train
we meet together
is that how you it's how you call what
you call it i go train we meet again
because at the very end of the hang with
dennis quaid when i was saying goodbye
they were everything had been so
respectful and cool and it was when i
was doing that show girl code so i had
to get up early i was like oh i'm gonna
go shoot this thing
and right before i left uh the guy goes
um wait before you go you should bang
our roadie and i like couldn't believe
he [ __ ] up this perfect night
where nothing was sexual or anything
yeah and i threw my person i was like
train like [ __ ] you and i
left and then i was so pissed at train
and then i saw them a year later at a
at a music festival that i was doing
comedy at and we were they had like a
shitty cafeteria for the comedians
but we couldn't find it so they finally
let us go into like one of the nice
cafeterias
and train was there and i went train we
meet again and i threw my back down and
he was like
i'm sorry i'm sorry and we took like a
selfie
so now we're cool we follow each other
so he like always remembers meeting you
yeah
that's kind of cool i made a scene when
he did that
wait train told you to bang a crew yes
oh but he apologies she on train
i would never expect that from him isn't
dennis clay like dating like a 20 year
old yeah she's pretty though no i think
she's old enough
i saw her she's 30. yeah she's no he was
dating someone who was 30 for like
five years like moved in with her and
then he oh yeah this girl
he he broke up with her after eight
years and then this girl he started
dating for six months and then got
engaged after six months
she was sad for another girl yeah that
was awful i was like that's so sad
i always remember how simon cowell's
long-term girlfriend
how he would say he would never have
kids and then he got the next girl
did she work on e or something yeah
extra yeah
i always feel that's such a bummer but
you never know what's going on she
probably like
did she want to be married to simon
county maybe she didn't really i feel
like she did
i don't know somebody once told me
something really heart-wrenching when i
was younger in my 20s and it stuck with
me
and it said men don't choose the right
partner they choose the right time
yes i've heard i feel like i've heard
that on sex in the city perhaps
i heard it in my ancient was it when i
was studying hebrew or was it
that's sex that show scarred me i feel
like the lesson of that show is like
get a man or you're old it's like it's
just not good or you're the [ __ ] that
gets cancer
you're like oh my god i know at the
beach house and then she chose
she was like i want to be alone okay i
have a question i've been following
i i've watched all your stuff always
i've been i've been up to date
um with all the like drama
what's drama like behind the scenes
what's happening with you and gila
because she's your sister-in-law right
yeah and
you you're like kind of seemed to be in
like this public fight with ethan
but are behind the scenes like is
everything okay are you not worried
long-term because like
you know you guys are going to your
family yeah it really
yeah it's such a messy thing i should
note that i was like
going to come on here even before friend
of mine's ended because we had this book
like before and in front of me
and i was like oh and hopefully you guys
don't get hate for having me on because
i did one interview since post front of
me and you got so much hate like we hate
her
so there's a big head can't he campaign
right now worry about it we don't we
don't believe in that
okay in our locus of control yeah um no
i i've always been fine with her
actually she's always been really nice i
have no issues with ela it's like
literally what's between me and ethan
but ethan like drags like a lot of
people and obviously it says why so
obviously
but like personally like you know we
haven't talked or anything but like i'm
totally
we've never had an issue i think it's
more because i'm like
ethan and i i'm like totally over it now
i mean i don't know but
you guys talked no we're like really
yeah did you guys during that time that
things were going down like
consider like uh you know how they have
those work therapists
oh okay the couple's therapist but for
um no i was on a show where uh i was
co-starring with my best friend at the
time and like it was
really a lot a lot like we were doing so
much and so
we like saw a therapist for a few
sessions and it really helped us
really yeah yeah i think i ended the
show peacefully
yeah so the network ended the show but
that is a really tricky thing and a
really
big gamble to um work with family yeah
or work with really like close friends
but also the show was called frenemy so
you knew there was like the contention
of course yeah and that's why everyone
was saying too they're like well that is
the show and it's like
i always thought that was the show too
you know but then you know it's fine it
is what it is but like yeah i always
thought that too i feel like if it was
like a reality show like the drama helps
it
yeah but i think there was just like a a
point of just
not it's not working anymore and so
they're very like no drama and i'm very
drama unintentionally but um like i
understand your
your point of view and your side of i i
thank you yeah i understand what
happened from what i
from what i understand whatever but i'm
i'm curious
do you're to moses and neil like are
they like back channeling like well you
and ethan are fighting are they like
because they're brother and sister like
everything's okay like
yeah you know i know i guess that was my
issue uh
because ethan said like his family is so
mad at him we talked to his mom this
morning and she goes
i love trish like tell her i love her
and like his brother's coming out to
stay with us like we're all cool like
the family
um again they like him and gila probably
talk and stuff like that but he doesn't
like tell me as much or whatever but
ethan's like dragged his mom into it and
all stuff like that so it's becoming
more of a family issue than it had to be
in my opinion
because it really was like i had this
issue with ethan and i get okay it also
involves either because that's your wife
but then like involving like family in
israel and this you know because they're
like we're cool we thought it was done
as of this morning like we thought
everything you know whatever so um
yeah i don't know i i don't i haven't
heard from you like either of them like
hopefully i mean we have a wedding and
so hopefully and we
did family activities before so
hopefully yeah and like you you you and
moses want to start a family and they
obviously have kids it's like
yeah you guys are going to be a family
regardless yeah
so right and it's going to be babies
involved yeah i think i feel like time
is so fresh and stuff but you're so
like right now it's just like a lot of
like whatever it's
it's not different from any other family
drama right like these things happen
in our own families yours is just
heightened because it's in
the public eye and so it's like that's
when it gets a little and she made a lot
of videos
which i deleted i'm like you know yeah i
deleted all of them because i'm really i
really
am like okay let me just disengage and
not do this because like going back and
forth like obviously we just don't see
eye
so it's just like a lot yeah so i just
kind of pulled the plug on that but
um but like when you were saying like we
started the show and it's hard to work
with family like i think at the time me
and moses were
like just started officially dating for
like a month so i think in his head like
everyone else is like oh this is like
not gonna last
but everyone said like even when myanmas
was dating they like ethan
or they told moses like don't date
trisha it's gonna end in disaster
so i don't know why he decided to start
a show with me if he thought our
relationship would end in a disaster but
it is you guys are unfortunately magic
together
manny's i i know it's really sad it's
really sad
i i i'm very excited my mom she hasn't
watched anything she didn't even watch
my own podcast
she watches frenemy yeah well they
probably don't talk about her
yesterday you have trisha tomorrow oh
yeah and i'm like oh my god ma watch my
[ __ ] subscribe to mine
you have to you're like i want all these
podcasts did your mom talk like that she
have an accent yeah she's a really
thick accent i love accents i love
accents that's so cool but she's in love
with you
oh is she here is she in l.a she's not
oh she should be upstairs cleaning but
i don't wanna i mean yeah i don't wanna
like make you feel bad about it because
i think like that
it just happens but do you feel like
because i i have seen you've you guys
have quit before
do you feel like this is this quit is
gonna stick or is there any chance
you know for me i i did i quit i quit
the show like three times and then we
brought dr drew back and it was fine
so for me in my head when i say i quit
something like and this is such a
it's a toxic pattern so i'm not saying
it's okay but every time i quit or if i
just you know i don't know what the
disney world was i would always be like
i want to break up with you and then he
just like
in an hour i'm like totally fine i do
that too right okay so
you get it so that's how i was i was
pissed after argument
but then literally an hour later he's
like hey we paid five thousand dollars
for this raid room tomorrow do you want
to do it like obviously yes
so i was like down to film the next day
it was gonna be fine
and then he texted me i was like i don't
the crew is really mad at you right and
that made you feel like alienating yeah
so then i was like oh well then i'm just
like quitting and i did my quit video
and then it turned into a snowballed
into his thing because then he did a
video about you
feel as though when you put a video out
like that that
you can't you now you have to double
down like you ever feel that way where
you're like you impulsively feel so
rageful
yeah and then even though you're not
necessarily feeling like you want to
like follow through with the quitting
but now it's out there so you have to
double down on that decision yeah
i was doing that like tenfold i was
definitely down doubling down
you know what i mean and then there is a
point of like almost like no return
right like i
i felt in my opinion that i was being
like respectful like you know because
like there was a time when i like came
freeloa when she wasn't involved that
was six months ago and we like i thought
we moved past and then he threw it in my
face again this past time
and it was like so ugly and so awful and
it was just all on my end now he left
side so
this time i was like you know i was i
didn't name call which is like a huge
improvement for me usually i like when
i'm in a fight i like
name call i want to like i'm the meanest
so i thought this time i handled myself
well but for some reason this was like
the biggest one that everyone's hanging
on to and like we hate trisha now
so it's i could tell that the way you
handled the fight that
that they aired on the show it's like
you clearly were
trying like a new coping mechanism of
just like i'm gonna like you're like
let's end it like
you're powering down like let me walk
away from the situation which
like is the kind of the right move right
i'm different i come from a very very
dysfunctional family
so it's like let's lay it all out and
let's work through it because
ultimately i know that we love each
other that's an undeniable
fact we're just not working through the
other
stuff that is muddying up the water so
like
my thing is to not ever run away which
is maybe a very unhealthy
pattern for me because i stick around
in possibly like make bad relationships
but i and in therapy i talk about is
like why is my threshold so high
like why do i want to always make it dig
in yeah like i just i'm like come on we
got this we can do this and
and i think that ultimately i do that if
i if i feel like there is this like
foundation of like love there yeah and
um
i don't know if that um you know it
speaks to you guys but like
and again i don't know you and ethan in
that way but when i look at you guys
together and that dynamic like
there is that like
like tangible love like i see it you
know
yeah and i think that's why also too it
was like so explosive because it's
always the people around me that like
get at the worst like i'm never like
i don't just go off on people i don't
know you know like i keep that in but i
feel like it is the people closest to me
like me and moses had a really big one
last year that like
that's when i was like okay i really do
need to get on medication because i have
like because i do have something wrong
with me i'm borderline and i'm
schizophrenia
it's schizophrenic and so i just got on
medication for that and like i feel like
it's helped a lot but the problem is is
i was got put on the at the end of may
and this was june 8th so
i think like during the transition time
like it takes like four to six weeks for
medication i probably like shouldn't
have been on
the the podcast because i think it was
just like i felt like like you were
saying i felt like i was trying to
disengage because that's what they teach
you
like in borderline yeah they're like
same thing with moses because it's like
for me
i just get angrier and angrier which is
like not good but when i sleep on
something like oh no what did i do you
know i felt
so that's that's where the doubling down
then came in but
yeah i i feel like i should have been i
don't know i feel like it's
i feel like it's just too far gone like
you never know yeah i think that like
really you have no control over what
other people think of you
or feel about you especially in this
like public eye that you're in
so it's really like just being true to
yourself learning your own lessons being
your best self and like
not being mad at yourself for things you
did and just like having an open heart
thank you i appreciate that that's where
i'm at too because i would spiral before
and i think a lot of it is i'm co-depend
on moses and i have moses i think if i
didn't if i was like single i'd be like
spiraling so much because that's what i
used to do all the time so the internet
knows me like crazy or whatever
but i feel like now it's like or even
being here you know just being around
like people outside of the internet
because the his fans are so hardcore and
they're like
fu and all this like crazy stuff so it's
like oh my god but then like being here
and you're like
we don't care what you know like the
real like other people like it is it's
it's really between me and ethan and
then obviously people from these
fans are upset or whatever but i don't
know when you get in the real world
they're like okay it's
not as serious as it feels and yeah i
can't i can't change what i did i did an
apology he didn't accept it
and that's totally fine but it's like
there's nothing more i can do i can't go
back in time
that's almost better though because you
did it for yourself and it wasn't like
i really have been trying in my life to
not do things for to get an
outcome from something you know and just
to really do it like from me outward and
then whatever happens happens
but you know what i said that in my
apology too because i was like you know
maybe this is kind of selfish that i
want to do this for me because i feel
really bad about and people were like
wow the apology wasn't even for ethan
like you're just doing it for selfish
reasons and i was like
but in a way like that is what i had
taken from it because he didn't want to
accept it and again it's fine but it's
like i had to release it for me because
i felt so much guilt
like no matter what you do you're always
you're you're at that level where
there's
always going to be people who are upset
about what you did and you know what
like
the commenters are like a half a percent
of the actual
people who are watching and i think my
mom
yeah i love my mom while she's really
upset about the breakup
she's like i love both of them oh she's
not siding with anyone
i love that and those are the true
stamps yeah yeah it's like the people
who are just watching quietly like you
said like most people
most people are watching quietly they
buy a couple tickets to the live show
they buy their merch and they never
well they never voice their opinion and
i feel like that's that is we have to
remember that's the majority of who
we're like
here to entertain also you have no clue
like so many times like if i've like
gotten triggered by a comment that
someone's made if i go
back at them they're like oh my god i'm
sorry i'm a big fan it's like
so i'm really trying to like release my
judgment even on people that are like
you're a fat [ __ ] like i'm just like
i don't know what your day is but it's
like because if i'm judging them i'm
pissed like it's my
now i'm attaching and i'm like letting
them have my energy and the amount of
times annie and i have been called
refrigerator bodies
like he's right in a weird way i was
like wait what's the refrigerator
it's like a square or a try a rectangle
oh my god that's what i'm saying no
matter what people always say because
you guys are like
model as beautiful like skinny and i'm
just like dang like and then they get me
they call me like little porky pig and
stuff like that so they're just not
happy refrigerator porky
whatever i mean what are your thoughts
like
miss piggy [ __ ] at least like i'm high
i love miss piggy
what are your thoughts on i know that
people are tying it to the pizza curse
but is there really something to
having pizza and him dressing as a cool
did you guys have pizza both times okay
so
we're we're obviously friends but i
think our biggest disagreement between
the three of us was right
whether we like dominoes or papa john's
uh
that true i think there's something to
the pizza curtains oh that's so weird
well that's so weird because i've been
eating domino's like my entire life like
i eat it like three times a week so i
don't know maybe it's like eating it
with people or something but i've always
eaten
maybe you don't have all these
personality disorders you just said and
maybe you just it's dominoes
can i ask you about um schizophrenia
yeah um what are
um to what degree to what degree do you
do you have like auditory hallucinations
i have auditory and visual yeah do you
have a um smell
no and do they come in like when you're
off the meds
um is it something that's like chronic
that you get every day or do you have
um bigger um what do you call it like
episodes
it was getting to be every day which is
why i like saw help because i thought i
got
diagnosed with borderline in 2019 i was
in like three months hospitals that year
so i was like oh i'm just borderline
that's it like i didn't think there was
anything more
and then um i started like developing i
started hearing things in my head like
it was started off like bells and
whistles and stuff like that and i
actually like applied for this like
reality show it was like right before
quarantine hit and we
were taking out this thing i was like do
you see like shapes that aren't like you
know do you see like animals that
aren't there so i would always see like
animals i would see shapes i would see
all this stuff like that that were like
not there and i was thinking like and i
was on i was doing a lot of xanax so i
thought the time it was like a xanax
thing so
my doctor's like no just get off xanax
like you know my therapist so it was
like get off the next you're fine you're
not schizophrenic all this stuff like
that
but um when it started to be voices and
it was like voices with people that were
next to me like my sister
i'd be like oh no that's that's not it
and she goes what are you i didn't say
anything you know so i was like having
conversations
hearing her have the conversations yeah
and so
i they used to be really dark voices and
um
then the darkness kind of went away it
was really like and people would say
well what did
ethan actually was like oh those are
interesting thoughts but they were more
than like intrusive thoughts there was
like literally someone telling me
there's a very
big line between intrusive thoughts and
actually like there's a person
yeah to me there was a person like next
to me you know i would hear
like family members next to me being
like oh you know if you just like
there's a window like i didn't go
upstairs for our house for the first
month like you know there's a window you
should just jump out of it
and then like you know you'll see your
grandma you'll see all these things like
it was very like comforting voices and i
never was suicidal i never heard voices
when i was a kid i did and i was taken
for um
diagnosis and it wasn't schizophrenia
they gave me bipolar medication i was
really young it was like i was on
lithium a couple times um
um but yeah and it was weird they kind
of subsided i don't know if it's because
like i did
i was doing a bunch of drugs for most of
my life here in hollywood i don't know
what it was
but they would subside and then i don't
know like last year it started to get
bad and then this year got really bad
and then they went from like dark voices
when i started going there's one thing
called cognitive group therapy i've been
doing
and it's like other i don't get too much
into it but other
other than like they started like
helping me and then i was starting to
hear like more
positive voices but it was more just
like every day like i thought moses
would be talking to me and he wasn't you
know but he'd be sitting right there
and then the visual stuff i see a lot
and
that's more daytime like in the sun and
stuff like that like i see a lot of
animals i see a lot of shapes
that weren't there and um i still see i
still
see shapes and those are like a whole
new thing and i didn't know that was
like a thing but i see like
squares and triangles that up here and
bells do you see refrigerators in front
of you
does moses ever say i love you and
you're like i'm hearing things
right i wish i could control like what i
hear from people because it's always
it's always just random stuff too
whatever
um but yeah the medication helps so much
like
with it because if i ask which which
what you're on it's called like clipta
kleptor klepto i've been called one of
those before
it's something like i've been waiting
really really difficult
yeah it's scary it's so scary it's like
really
scary because i and a lot of people like
you don't just develop
you know people on the internet have
like all this like they're so [ __ ]
annoying yeah they're like you don't
just develop it i'm like i don't know
what to tell you like
i just started hearing voices like love
and light love and light loving life
love and light i know it's like so but i
went to two
different uh psychiatrists like i went
to two before getting on my kitchen i
don't like be on medication i've never
like i've been on medication improperly
and i got off it right away because
those are the only times i've ever been
like
like suicidal thoughts were on
medication medications like never liked
it um
but that's the one thing they don't tell
people that are newly on meds is that
the first month that you're
on it is the window of time that you
should be watched the most
because if you have any type of suicidal
ideation um let's say for instance
you're down into pits
um this is coming for me because i've
been in and out of like
hospitals on 5150s and whatnot and
um so when i had suicidal ideation
it was never when i was the most
depressed that i ever tried to hurt
myself
it was when i finally got on meds and so
the suicidal ideation was still there
but now i had the energy to execute
yes so now i had the energy to actually
carry out what my plan versus just being
like
this veg sad vegetable in bed and so um
that first month is really like what
what like for anybody that's like
watching like
watch your family members watch your
kids watch your loved ones when they're
first getting on mats it doesn't just
it's all better you know yeah oh my gosh
was
when you went to the men when you went
to the hospitals where did you find that
they helped you
because i felt like mine made me like
worse like they forced medication on me
that i shouldn't have taken
um i found some really great friends
there
yeah um so the guy you [ __ ] yeah i
know were they
were they real
place the third place i went to in
torrance and i was there for about three
weeks
um i didn't know it at that time i
didn't equate it to like bad behavior on
his part at that time but i eventually
dated one of the counselors there and he
asked for my number the day that
he was helping me pack you're like my
number is uh 16.
i don't know it's my mom's phone and he
wasn't he was a dad like
he claimed to be a single dad but now
i'm thinking i'm like oh
maybe you know maybe well it's always
those people that are dealing with
at-risk teens
i don't want to get the molested belly
oh my god i don't yeah i don't believe
in much i when i was in my mental
hospital i went to el hamburg
which one bhc huh bhc's yeah yeah have
you been
yes twice
it was just a long hallway just one long
hallway and it was the rooms on the side
on each side yeah
and then there was like the room where
you color at that corner yes and then
you had to go across like your
level two was you get to go out to
dinner across the way to like the dining
hall
to go out oh my god imagine being a
waitress at that place
like these are not good tippers actually
i wonder how you paid i guess my family
came and visited me because they did
visiting hours like 6 p.m or something
yeah and they always say they had like
your contraband you weren't allowed to
like hold anything in your possession
that you could not even like
safety pins they check everybody
because everyone is they go they don't
go in your vagina
no they don't no but they have guys
check on you like in the middle of the
night when they do their checks like
it's a guy
ours was a guy that like did a
flashlight in there to like and i'm like
oh like and you're like this little
sheet whatever
and then the ed units like connected to
it so like the people who are going
through like their eating disorders they
were like on the other side i thought it
was erectile dysfunction i was like
they get a area in their own section
that's crazy oh my god no it was like
and it would you know and you
it was so it was so uncomfortable
because like you could go across the way
to the dining hall but if you didn't do
that you had to eat there and like the
people with the ed would be there too
well that was what was um interesting is
that we did have a lot of girls with
eating disorders
there and um we were just all mixed in
together and we would have group therapy
together
so it was like a very like i learned a
lot about
all the other different things that
people were going through
um and so for that reason i'm out
it was it was a good experience like it
was more of like a learning experience
because you're very empathetic
did you ever like did you think you like
took on their eating disorders a little
bit
no i had i my mom is a [ __ ]
bodybuilder of course i was
meant to have an eating disorder but
that wasn't my main issue my main issue
was like a whole lot of like obviously
like childhood like sexual trauma and
stuff like that so yeah
um can i ask you about borderline
because i feel like that's a really
big one that you hear a lot about but
i've never heard any doctors
yeah i've never heard anyone say like i
was diagnosed with borderline
there's a ton on tick-tock now i feel
like i'm on bpd tick-tock yeah there's a
lot
it's so funny because like it became
somewhat like trendy now this borderline
and so but then when you like exhibit
borderline behaviors people are like oh
like too much you know what i mean
which is serious yeah it is because
there's like episodes and you know you
you there it's just always manic high
manic lows i mean it is what it is and
you gotta you gotta just control it and
with bbt there's no medication for it so
it's like you i go to dbt classes which
is like group therapy classes
so i'm in two group therapies now and so
um it's expensive right isn't it like
it's
yeah it's something you have a lot of so
expensive and what's expensive
the the therapy the group therapy and if
you're in the group there if you have to
be an individual therapy
yeah so you have to be in both at the
same time like simultaneously and it's
like
it's super expensive yeah and it's um
it's a it's a lot of work and
obviously it doesn't happen overnight so
like when people are like oh i thought
she was getting better and then she's
it's like i have gotten so much better
this last blow-up compared to the one in
december
like that it was better if people see it
or whatever but i've gotten better it's
just really trying to regulate your
emotions which is like really hard for
me to do and i like want to snap back
i'm so
impulsive and i'm so reactionary so
which is how i ended up in the hospital
too like the
alhambra i was just like that was the
one i was forced to go i was at cedar
sinai and they forced me because i was
just so reactionary you know what i mean
like i
that's when we'll just say it like jason
and david came into the hospital and i
just like
lost my [ __ ] i took off my clothes i ran
away i was trying to find a pen to like
stab myself and like
it was crazy it was like so intense so i
um
yeah then they forced me to go there but
it was just it's just like really these
reactionary things that are just get me
in trouble which is what happened on the
podcast and
yeah it's it's no fun and borderlines
yeah when they came to see you was it
for a [ __ ] vlog no no no i was gonna
say
i think i would be [ __ ] pissed you
know well it felt that way though
because
i like exploited me yeah because jason
had just broken up with me that day
and david was ignoring me because i made
a video about him like so i was exiled
from the group already so this was like
four days five days after i was exiled
so whatever that's so dramatic but yeah
they came and um
my makeup artist was the one that like
called 911 and went to the hospital with
me
and then he he told like he told jason
like i was back in the middle of the
hallway and then i saw david come back
and i lost my [ __ ] because i was like
no you're the reason like all this i was
so pissed i was like why are you here
because
and i never heard from him since which
is why i mean he's so fake because it's
like he never
was like after like are you okay because
jason came to visit me at the mental
hospital like
you know people knew and they didn't
even like check on me i'm like okay fake
friends whatever yeah to even be like
i'm not cool with you but like are you
okay you know yeah
it's mine i mean it is what it is it
happened so like long ago but yeah
the alhambra one was like crazy i met
this boxer she's open about it so i feel
like i can but her name is mia st john
and her sister
you do i know of her yeah her son well
and her
late uh her first husband like they both
committed suicide
and her son did it in a mental hospital
yeah
and so that's why she was in there and
she was like saying like and then her
husband was a famous soap opera actor
who
who killed himself too and she talks
about it and i've seen her on stuff and
i've
tried to connect with her since getting
out of there but she was in there like
sharing her story and i was like you
where i like listen to other people's
stories and you're just like whoa and
then there's some people in there who
are in there for life because they just
don't have anywhere else to go
and yeah it was crazy i tried to get out
there as soon as i could but this is
where it gets a little bit tricky and
ties into the whole britney spears thing
is that
like because i learned a lot about
conservatorship
and you know from my understanding of it
it doesn't look as like
life like as thieving as britney spears
situation is like
conservatorship is meant to protect like
both like the family and the person
who's like ill
right yeah and that [ __ ] right there
when i looked at it i was like oh my god
that girl is
in an actual prison yeah but i wanted to
ask you trish
um on a scale of one to ten
one being front of me says absolutely
over
look at her look at her she's doing this
for her mother
her mom okay i'm gonna go from zero to
ten zero being it
absolutely over and ten being full
fully back on the family is happy we're
doing it
where where are you today just you not
even
like just regardless of what ethan's
feelings are
like how do you feel today um i think if
you ask me this like yesterday i would
have said like 10 i'm ready to come back
but today it's a 0.5 because after he's
like the family hates trish i was like
this [ __ ] like i was like that
is not true
so i think that really set me back like
could you though look at it like this
like
and i could be completely wrong could
you look at it knowing that the family
doesn't hate you could you look at it
like those are his
tools he's using to try to trigger you
and not be triggered by it
just trigger me and not be checked
no could you see like if you know like
you have a great relationship with the
family yeah
and you trust that mm-hmm yeah for sure
so him saying that to you
is a dig at you but it's not the truth
for sure it's coming from a place of
hurt
like could you see that is that's his
attempt to get you to be triggered
and then is there a way for you to just
like reflect it off
yeah like like let it go like like shine
the light on it
because i need a number to go up a bit
for my mom for my mom
um i mean you know i'll just say i don't
know if i should say this but
it's fine whatever so he actually asked
me to come do like one final episode on
monday
right like but i don't just be like
between us because after that i was like
i don't really trust it
yeah because i saw him do the sick
interview with like a conservative
person like this debate or did you see
that
like pranks yeah steven crowder and then
he like did a switch he kind of like
ambushed him and switched him with like
someone to debate him and it was like it
was a little tricky and i
he hasn't told me details and because he
did that and because he said i do not
accept the trust apology i think it's
like it almost feels like a setup where
he may be trying to ambush me
that's how i trust that instinct right
that sounds yeah i like it
originally i said yes i wanted to come
on because he has merch made and i was
like i'll help you
is there a way for you to have control
over that more like can you
have it on your terms like are you able
to have him come to you
and like could you have a crew filming
it
or like is there some contract i think
once i saw it because this week he had
his parents on and they were just like
trashing me his dad says something about
my weight
his mom said i was toxic you look so
cute by the way
you're like the first person i wear i'm
like starstruck in person like you're so
pretty
i know i'm like i want the hair i'm
gonna like really like i gotta plan for
you guys i don't look like this most of
the time i'm usually like show her hair
or not
i got glam glammed for you
[Laughter]
once on fiverr no i saw your
ex-boyfriend on taskrabbit oh is there a
better
is there a [ __ ] better revenge and
i'm a very good friend for telly
that is literally the funniest but i'm
just gonna go ahead and say like i
cannot live without taskrabbit so kudos
to him and all the side hustlers there
what's taskrabbit that's true yeah no
yes we don't dave is so not a man he
can't even hang
posters on our wall we have we have like
a hot guy out taskrabbit who comes and
does everything for us
oh it's like a handy yeah it's a
handyman it's an app for a hand it's
like an uber for handyman um
i'm going to call it we're going to take
a banana break on the show trish we have
this thing called
when the feelings are high we bring them
back down with a banana every episode
yeah we have like a little it's like a
relaxed chitchat a little it's a
potassium re-up
do i get anything today do you want
actually my nana no no she doesn't
participate in bananas you don't have to
i
they have a separate fruit for me
because i don't like bananas but when i
went to visit my parents they were like
giving me [ __ ] about it trish do you
want a less bruised banana than that i
actually like bruised bananas okay i do
i'm like
that is it's nice such a cute metaphor
i like a bruised banana i dated many
bruised bananas
yes i am a bruised banana i am oh this
is so cool
so what's the potassium do um she's a
nurse
i just it's just an electrolyte re-up
for me
um also i have a heart condition and
potassium is my best friend
so what is is it was that related to
your implants or it's just
we don't know we don't know because i
was an athlete for a really long time
like
uh i don't know i don't know but i have
um
my heart rhythm goes awry and so like if
i'm sleeping it'll go up to like
230 beats a minute and it'll stay there
and i can't breathe i get sweaty clammy
but i had surgery for it
did you get depressed like you know when
you get open heart surgery you get
depressed because it's like
you can't trust your body um i was
depressed way before that already the
whole not trusting my body thing was a
big thing
um and also it gets weird when you're
sick and like
your partner sees you as someone that's
sick oh my god what a bone
like for him oh really isn't it no
that's the opposite for me
i love being the sick one like that's
like sexual for me
yeah i feel the same way i'm always like
i mean i don't want to get sick but i'm
like oh because moses would be the best
caregiver and i'm like oh it's so hot
but also yeah like when my whenever i've
broken my foot or something like i've
gotten hit on by like every guy
trying to rape me i'm like jesus christ
i can't like run away
they love that like yeah you're now
within reach you're catchable yeah
you're a wounded bird
hobble away i think that's why they have
big boobs too because it hurts too much
to run
they're like i can trap your ass so
that's so interesting do you have
thoughts on like the future of like your
podcasting
life oh i would never do like another
one like if like if
like because it was so perfect like
esther started crying she was like i was
just
by the yeah can we just say that she
just said potassium's her best friend
i'm just imagining you doing a friend of
mine
it's just you and a banana fighting
and me and you're outside like let us
know can we get a little bit of this
that's an animated banana and we can
call it bruised banana oh my god that's
cute
so cute my banana this banana life
when you [ __ ] you guys you're out the
saddest thing i've ever heard
that's what you would you would never do
another best friend
i don't think so it would because i did
my own and it wasn't like fun by myself
like i like
having someone like i like going on
podcasts i love like talking to people
doing it by myself was like awful like i
don't like i i have a youtube channel
for that
i don't know i don't kind of imagine or
also it might be me too that i just
don't have that
that time commitment you know like i
feel like maybe i sabotage in a way
because it's like
after a while i kind of just get over
things and it's like a commitment every
week
yeah and i like doing it especially
because during quarantine but i don't
know maybe
i loved your music video by the way i
feel like you should take your time
for that type of stuff yeah you know
what i mean like when you have an idea
just like
execute it to its like fullest potential
i love you
for the music video so i'm being my
dream is to one day collab on a music
video
did you wait so you do like put out
music well she's a dancer
i i did it i sing she was a hand model
she's a dancer
i put a music video in my comedy special
so i've never like self produced like i
know you do
but i am a huge musical theater free oh
no i know i loved like i was obsessed
with crazy exercise like one of them
that's so i was like this is the show
because she was bored alive and she
loved musical theater and i was like
that's me
i loved that show i was like obsessed
yeah so when i saw you on there and you
were doing
i think there was like a colonial one
you were doing and i was just like
that's my
dream oh my god i loved it my um this
this guy
dated he was on that show he was like
the santa claus and i was like so
jealous he got to go on i want to go set
so bad and he like wouldn't let me
it was so cool i was like i just love
that show i remember your smash
music video and i thought that was
amazing oh smash
i live for a smash i live for christian
borah i love the broadway community like
that's where i want to be so that's why
i do my own music videos i'm not the
town i'm not talented enough to do that
i just you should make a one-woman show
i'm also not talented enough for that
like what you guys do with comedy like
it's so hard
esther is like produce oh you did do
stand up i did it once for like a show
are you come on in come babe and panda
underwear
bobby let's see her undies come on in
bobby
underwear i just woke up come here babe
quickly quickly
i forgot oh you look so good i know you
thank you
but just get in front of the camera
enough that you say cancel or something
for what
you look so good let them see you
can underwear everything here's
how i sleep oh my god i love it
bobby i like your new hair too still has
all the sleep markings you're saying
that's
you caught us on a banana break we're
still good oh you're bananas yeah you
have less nipple hair than all of us
except trisha i shaved down here too
okay oh no no
go get out of here
and then i didn't i didn't shave the um
in between the um
the sack and the thighs so it looks
weird melody
yeah it's a little molodyn you're my
favorite little lesbian
how was last night was it good i killed
i bet you [ __ ] did
it's gonna grow bobby it's gonna grow i
killed
everyone wearing it in the room i killed
for seven minutes
the beginning seven or the last seven i
didn't do 15. oh
you just got off good for you and i just
said
that's good good and then everyone was
like
[Laughter]
yeah just do whatever you want i'll do
seven i do seventy sometimes
my face yeah right so if you do seven
it'll just say [ __ ] faces
probably like cute like like sometimes
do that
no bye babe she liked it
it was like an expose is he on camera
this is what i love about bobby
he didn't want to come in but once we
got him
okay have fun bye bobby
there should be like not his job
is there a red bull in there there
should be there isn't that's the
funniest interaction i've ever heard in
my life is that how he sleeps
yeah that is so in my in my panties yeah
we share we share underwear i love it
what is that i got one in my bag i
always carry one in my bag
oh it's nice you guys don't share
underwear with your
are you crazy no i cannot know i cannot
fit into his underwear
um we share clothes
all of our from head to toe socks
everything we share everything
it's perfect because um he wears
everything under his socks you stick
your toes through them
the socks she was wearing last time well
he wears everything under his belly
so um he actually fits he buys um pants
sized to me and we share yeah that's
cute
he's skinny he's so skinny it's so weird
how i i've always had this too i feel
like everyone looks better naked i
really do
i think that too i feel like me i look
better nick i don't like like fat naked
i don't know clothes can bulk you up if
you don't want to dress yeah
more people should just be naked he
looks so skinny i was like oh my gosh
because he always calls himself like
well like a meatball or something and
i'm like oh he's like tiny he's like a
spaghetti noodle
it's so cute i want to come see you guys
a show what are you guys at comedy store
i want to come
this weekend i'm there either i'm going
to be a little while um i'll probably
start going in a couple weeks
i just have to be taking a break but uh
you're on the road again soon
yeah in the fall i'm gonna go yeah i
love st i love stand up i do
well you did stand up yeah it was a show
it was a show and an improv i think
on youtube yeah yeah yeah it was like a
show i know everything about her
i'm not gonna pretend i don't i did so
many like cavities no
it was like one where you're like a
mentored by like a stand-up i can't
think of a guy's name that mentored me
now and so like yeah
you practice for like a day and then
it's awful i don't want to watch it it's
so cringe
it's so it's so hard like i can never do
standpoint but i think you're
you have true comedic instincts and
you're very funny like
you you're clearly like there's
something comedic about you like don't
you you must agree
yeah i yeah right people she's so funny
but i do think it is
um i don't know i'm really bad at like
having to make jokes up on the spot you
know
but also maybe because you said that you
like
podcasting better with another person
maybe you would be better at
maybe improv or at um doing crowd work
so you're like talking to people
rather than just like up there it's also
there's like stage fright you have to
get through
yeah how standards can just go up there
like tell stories and like make
that's like practice it's just probably
i think that's like you have to know how
to just stand up there and be funny for
like an hour i don't know how people do
it it's so it's
like you have to fail at it a lot yeah
really
machine you have to become a bomb
machine it just has to stop
hurting and then it's like easy it's
also like the delivery all that stuff is
like an art
it's really cool i love watching like
stand-ups i think that's like so cool i
did that show who wants to be a comedian
i want and i won and the guy was
the greg the greg something yeah it
wasn't the greg wilson do you know him
oh
oh oh my gosh wait a minute i'm sorry
his name was like the greg well said i
didn't know him it was like a shower
yeah why why did you end up
um dating commit comics and like how did
you end up like
mixed in with that scene well so i
worked i i we talked about the guy that
was creepy that like hit on youtube that
guy that sold me remember last episode
the one that's little meat out of his
truck oh guys hit on me too
yeah oh he still hits on me and i'm like
engaged and he like hits me up i just
feel so insulted i've not been hit on by
the meat man
he was all me out of this like vegans
are hitting on me
no you worked at the comedy store yeah
so i would be there
because i did that show for laugh
factory the one with don marrera it was
like a court case show so i like
i just was like there a lot and then i
like was an assistant to that one
comedian and i've assisted like other
comedians um
so i think i was just like always like
around and i i was just like a fan i was
like a groupie until i because i thought
oh comedians they you know they're so
self-deprecating they was like hate
themselves dude but they're like the
biggest narcissist
so i was just i thought they were gonna
be like cute and like the nerdy guys
because it's comedy and comedy's like
not hot but they like think they're like
rock stars so crazy i had to completely
stop dating comedians
it's so disgusting but i will say my
last ex boyfriend's like their best
laughs i'm like i wrote that [ __ ]
really sitting in the back like i wrote
that that's yeah
yeah i just i never read but it just i
ended up being like like writing for
them and stuff it was like i was like
there
and how does that work you write for
someone and do they like give you credit
are you they can't
no they don't give you [ __ ] credit
really so you just do it for fun or they
would just be like hanging out and like
i mean they would give me tags too but
it's like you just like
i mean i kind of am a tag giver too
which annoys people
i try to give esther when she's but she
won't do them
give me the thing i'm refusing to go on
stage
in that stage of being a comedian
is a weird time having like had all this
time off from kobe yeah
i'm like now back very excited about it
but last night i was like i'm going on
with no plan
and i had a heckler which was kind of
okay but it was you know it's like i go
back and forth it's just like now i'm
like looking at it like each time it's
like i just wanna have a different
experience so
i'm probably banned now because i talk
so much [ __ ] about like all male comics
i never had a bad experience like a
female
like never i don't think it's different
now the comedy store the booker
the booker's a female and then she gets
help from another woman and it's like
very feels like the vibe feels very
feminine
that's good yeah i feel like they needed
that maybe yeah well
things got flushed out right yeah would
you say that your
public persona like when you when you
just you as trish when you do
youtube videos are you kind of playing a
character
like a little bit ah i don't know i
would say i
like now i feel like i'm not but who
knows i feel like
i do feel like i become like a little
bit of a different person like hair
makeup versus when i don't people notice
that all the time i do think it's also
like
also just like something wrong with me
that i like switch personalities because
i'm very like
uh who i'm around i try and be like you
know what i mean so i relate to that
yeah so i think you know when i and then
when i'm in like glam i feel like i'm a
little more
ditzy and i'm a little more you know
daring and bold as opposed to when i'm
ugly i'm like oh my gosh
don't be stupid like don't be annoying i
don't know maybe maybe i think i'm
pretty authentic to myself i feel like
if you know me like off camera and i
feel like i'm pretty much the same as
most of someone like ethan who's like
really like loud and stuff on camera but
like really sweet and like quiet like
off camera so it's like he's i
a lot of people are like that you know
they're really on and then you like see
them behind camera they're like really
just like
it's also weird i also think it's it's a
way
um i know for me like i try to be
i think that i'm being as authentic
let's say on a podcast
but when the cameras are on i'm so like
conscious that they're on and i also
like i'm so anxious that they're on
so i don't think that like i think that
these girls know who i really
am like outside of here because i not
that you know i could just be
not as well as potassium though but i
think that it's a way to also like
protect yourself to sort of play up this
like persona
so that you keep a little bit of
yourself to just you like only my family
really knows me in this capacity
like at least for me i think i think i
used to be like that like i used to be
like this like
really hardcore dumb i was trying to be
like so like you know i love trump and
just like anything that was opposite of
me because i thought like if it wasn't
me then no one knew i think i used to be
like that a lot
i try and be more authentic but i it is
it is hard i think on
cameras i don't know yeah it's hard to
know like i
am i feel like i've had people ask me
that like are you really
like that or are you just playing a
character and that's and i'm always like
i don't know yeah yeah it's like kind of
blurred
because you're used to playing like
characters so you're like i don't know
if this is like well sometimes with that
storm like you don't know what a noogie
is
i'm like is that real and then she
really doesn't know what a [ __ ] name
we gave her a nugget for the first time
last episode but i'll be like i'm like
i'm like wanting it to be a character
i'm like
i don't know it's nice she liked it
it was like a gentle one are you an only
child i'm a half only child so i have a
half older sister who's seven years
older oh okay so you weren't getting
like nuggied
no yeah no wedgies no
i don't that [ __ ] is like that's like
isn't that illegal
it's like assault
did that to me we didn't talk for six
months it's real it is disgusting it's
like yeah yeah people are spit off
get your covenant on my [ __ ] ears
yeah it's so nice i have some weird
um ear sensory issues so you cannot
touch my ear like
that's like have you seen um something
about mary warren yes the kid who has to
wear earmuffs
like that's me if you [ __ ] with my ears
or come close to it like i'm putting
hands on you oh god
so i understand the wet willy thing
esther oh
i have bad ears like i have swimmers
ears so they're i grew up with a lot of
like ear infections and just like
sensitivity around it
so like i don't i don't like you know
who gives wet willies though and it's
actually so funny
is john cleese the yeah it's so funny
like when you meet him
and his daughter is a comic right
camilla yeah but so he like
he'll like reach around like hug you and
then like in a picture again and it's
there i'm telling you he's like someone
that i grew up like
idolized it's the funniest but no
he wouldn't be able to reach i honestly
think he's very tall i don't know if he
would even be able to i don't care
who you are that's what if you idolize
them like you have someone that you're
obsessed
give you could she with you a wet willy
what if lady gaga gave you no no no
if lady gaga gave you a wet willy no
that's like it's real now
hang on then what would you say how
would you say how would you reject her
what willy i'd be like
gaga like
i would be i i ah i don't know i guess
i'd be like
would you put poker face
what if she just did it would you be
pissed or would be like oh it's fine
like it happened
i would have to move on quickly because
i love her so much
but and i would probably my time is
probably limited but
that would be tricky i don't know that's
[ __ ] violence
i want to see what esther's like when
her time's limited with me she's never
had limited time
i've always given her all the time
i would let my idol like [ __ ] on me i
wouldn't care i would be like just
do it you know like um i love gerard way
for my chemical
romance i would definitely let him like
[ __ ] on me i would
say like straight in the chest like a
hot car like chest is like very sexual
so maybe since i'm engaged maybe like on
my face if it's not sexual
it's so just gross i'd just be like oh
yeah that's him
yeah oh he's like is he your sad boy
by inspiration yeah we copy every music
video from them like we are an
unofficial mcr tribute band we so
instead of doing their music because we
want to get hyper i just like wrote
songs to fit the music videos that i
love from them but we do shop by shots
of all their videos
we have one next week that's like a 300
000 music video and it's their world war
two one and we got like a world war two
boat we're like on the beach like
we got bomb explosions yeah i'm i
literally i just was like
i would i was i keep saying this on
every practice i go on but i'll say it
again in case he's listening if you
perform at my wedding i'd give him
my life savings right now as of this day
to perform one song because i'm walking
down the aisle to helena
i love elena that's my favorite song
cry to that song it's so like that song
like resonates with me
so like i i'm just like esther you have
to get this to happen
this is your way you have so many
connections so if you can get that to
happen
i mean we look alike esther's gonna
dress like him and show up
to shop and sing
by the way dave grohl was at the party
that you couldn't make it to
whitney had a party at that was like for
the
it was like she put on like an
unofficial premiere for the christmas
craft
yeah and dave girl was there and i tried
to take a picture with him for you and
whitney was like get away from him and i
was like okay
you do know everybody everywhere you're
at like dave crawl
it's i mean i'm blessed if you see him
texting he doesn't go out he's like a
recluse but if you ever see him text me
i would
drop everything actually probably i'd be
scared to meet him actually i don't
think i would i don't know
don't you drop a lot of money on these
music videos
it's the best yeah like no
i make like a thousand dollars on the
music video maybe not even that
i want to clarify what music i liked
your music video to moses that was what
i was talking about oh that one
yeah that was so cute we have another
one coming out together that we're doing
yeah with all in hebrew
actually yeah the whole hebrew song but
um thank you that's so funny it's so
funny because that was like meant to be
like funny in a joke and people like
really that guy
was so cute thanks yeah i liked having
him on there he used to play like jesus
and like um like tv shows and stuff like
that so i think like
it was made sense for like biblical
moses to come out um
oh that means a lot i loved it i love
having him a music video he's gonna be
he's gonna be in this next one he'll be
i just want him in everything does he
like being in them
yeah i think so yeah because he like
acted briefly for a short time in his
life as jesus and i feel like
he's he's not uh what a career he was he
was jesus in like everything
but i i and also an actual architect
jesus was an architect and a wood maker
like a carpenter he's literally a
carpenter he makes like tables out of
wood he's literally jesus
he is jesus yeah and he's born in israel
like he's you know i was like oh my god
just right by bethlehem
well bethlehem's in palestine i guess
now but what do you think the specific
goal was for israel to pay because bobby
went there for
three weeks and so they they pay it's
like an all-expense-paid vacation and it
was just a bunch of
asian-americans so it was bobby lee
steve byrne
and a couple other like big people and
asian people in the industry and they
were there for a while and they got like
wine and dying why they just want people
to stay
they want to convert them they're like
convert maybe
i don't know yeah do they did he perform
there no was he single at the time
no we were together weird i was like can
i
i'm jewish
yeah that is so i feel like that reminds
you like how like you hear the stories
how hot models in l.a get like all
expenses paid stuff
you have to buy and all those things
that could be i mean i think most of all
his girlfriends over there were asian i
think they were like filipinos and stuff
so i don't know if there's a tie in
there but like over when he dated over
there and he's like i'm like oh that's
that your preference that you like you
know it's like i'm sorry and he's like
no just like it happened to be that you
apologize like i'm so sorry i'm not even
i'm sorry i apologize you can become one
now we found out
what if they sent bobby there to like
try and take the asian women away from
the jewish men
so the jews would be together and the
asians would be together
i don't know asian women find their way
everywhere because i
like all the mexican boys that used to
come to um
santa fe to work in the restaurant yeah
they would like they were the rich kids
in chihuahua
they would come work at the restaurants
and like live in santa fe for like six
months and i would always
bang them um wait tables with them but
um
they would always have like asian
girlfriends back home in mexico i just
feel like
you're like the asian community is like
we're we're down we're going
yeah i think they're just spreading out
90 days always like from philippines
yeah like that i think they're just open
to like
i hate the way the filipinos are
portrayed though on 90 day fiance
yeah it really hurts my feelings get on
that wait wait why okay i think i can
get you on there i
mean i loved ed and rose um
i just like they gave him too much of
um too too much of a platform
to make people think that she was only
in it for
like it it's as if it wasn't both ways
as if there weren't
things to be had for both of them you
know what i mean and not to say that she
isn't opportunistic
but it's like dude like you were in it
for something too
like let's see this isn't that [ __ ]
she was like really not
call it what it is like a mutual
transaction like she's not taking
advantage of you you're
equally taking advantage of her oh my
god the ulcer thing was where i just
when he got to no i was so angry at that
because poor rose she was like oh
like i have a stomach ulcer like i can't
like control like the
acidity of like my breath and stuff and
when i would see her cry because there
was a language barrier
and her not being able to express her
rage towards him yeah
really made me feel sad i don't know
like i mean she was you did get to see
she was pissed like
she looked like i i think she came out
looking good thank god yeah she didn't
leave him right
she left the hotel that they were at i
think she yeah and then she ended up
with a i think she's a woman
yeah yeah yeah he really she was like
we had ed on tiger belly oh you did
we did how was it one of our remote
episodes um
he he was nice he was as as you would
yeah
himself yeah um but i couldn't i have
trouble like confronting people like
when they're guests on our show
because i'm like i don't want to do that
now so i feel like i miss my opportunity
to be like why'd you do
my girl dirty like that you know yeah
breath
you can do it in a nice way because
you're so nice i feel like you could do
it in like a good way like a way that
especially because he probably you know
i don't know also i don't know i think i
know the lex comes out you got to watch
the eggs
i didn't facetime with this [ __ ] i was
like
[ __ ] i was like whoa it does it does
take a lot for me to
to snap but when i do it it
yeah um but i would love
to get snapped at by you by me because i
feel like i would just
like i like crave it like i just want i
want you sir
you if if i snap if i snapped at you i
think that
this friendship couldn't we couldn't
recover because i'm gonna go for the low
blows
yeah that's me too i'll snap at you i
can do it in nothing i'll trigger you
or trigger me i mean yeah i'm just i do
it just quicker i have like a but i do
hold things in too i think even the
thing with me
ethan i think i held in so much i'm like
i should probably talk about things
because then i do snap and then it just
becomes like a lot
this is why we get me in trouble
sometimes it's like fun it's like
exciting you know like to whatever
like it keeps you on your toes but we i
don't deal with moz anymore but for like
the first like six months of our
relationship
like i definitely was like on that line
of like throwing his keys over the fence
and then like we're fighting
and then we'd make was definitely that
but we're not that anymore because he
ended up dead leaving he's like okay too
many but now we're
now we're cool you're like okay i saw
the line yeah
exactly because he was always like so
cool i'd like throw his keys out and
he'd be like fine or whatever but
dude i used to do that to guys and then
when i i to dave
the first time i was like i think we
should just break up
and then he was looked at me he's like
okay and i was like never right i'm
sorry
oh instant regret i try so hard to not
do that i really try to like
really wait until i mean it yeah my
favorite part about being on facetime
with annie
is that when todd let's say for instance
like she you know
she he misses it's like something so
stupid around the house that maybe he
didn't do
my favorite thing that makes me laugh so
hard is todd
you're single you're single okay keep
that in mind
todd's single and i'll be like wow you
really
like let me mess the living room up
today this has been sitting here for all
day
look at you todd you're single that's
just so funny we don't even really like
we've gotten into like a few fights it's
just usually what i'm pmsing but
um he like he just will do things like
i'll
i'll be like hey can you pass through
the remote just like you guys
like he just makes me laugh all the time
like he's always having fake fights with
me it's so funny
you guys met right before quarantine
yeah that was us too so that quarantine
is like
just forcing you to be together it just
was so we had so much fun the whole time
like
even one i had like my apartment was
getting construction i had an ulcer like
all the our dog got mange like
all these stressful things i still look
back and i'm like the majority of the
day we like laughed and had a good time
yeah we really did have like fun and now
that it's getting back to the real world
are you guys like still it's the best
yeah we don't see each other as much
because i'm on the road a lot but
he's just like really good with people
that are difficult to work with
he just like is like you know he's he's
secure he's securely attached so it's
like really nice
i have anxious attachments so like uh i
like
but until dave proposed to me i was like
a maniac
and then right when he proposed i was
like okay i can rest and i was like
playing the wedding like get
off my deck yeah like i don't want to
get married i just
that is so funny me too i feel like i
mean i want to get married now obviously
but like i was so funny once i got
engaged just kind of oh this is all i
needed really because then it's just
whatever you wanted
yeah right well that's chosen you get
chosen by them
yeah they're like you're my person right
and like buying a house together i was
like oh this is like commitment like
i'm not leaving you're not leaving so
like the start you know so i i am the
same way
because like i think getting married
really is just for like i mean now that
we're like planning what i'm like oh
it's literally just like a party like
it's no different than anything but
yeah i don't know are you i i just know
we're all going to be there so
yeah yeah give me your addresses i want
to like send you guys i'll send you all
wedding
invites we're getting married in l.a and
israel and actually maui to new york
are we invited to all three
wait esther we're all in a fight by then
we have to pick one of the weddings one
of us is stuck with la well you don't
like vacations i'll do la
okay yeah i didn't have to give you maui
no no no i've been to maui many times
all right you can take maui i'll take it
i've never been to israel
i can't wait to see the banana in a tux
that you take
that would be so iconic because
literally no one from here is really
coming to israel like we've invited
people and said no
but that'd be everything we should come
oh our only american guest are you and
bobby
i mean trisha i can't even tell you i am
so there
really that 1000 percent yeah
choose which one you want to
thank you this is like yeah this is my
first like all female podcast and i like
love it
feels so good i feel like we're all like
the right amount of just like
open and not embarrassed no you guys are
open about everything like it's
insane like what you guys talk about
which is kind of everything like that's
cool because i always thought like i was
like this unicorn kiss i'm like
everyone's like wow
you're too much but you guys talk period
blood i was like oh my god okay i love
it though i love talking
last episode we're talking about dried
[ __ ] on our stomach
sorry george esther you're bringing it
up again esther is our [ __ ] queen
[Laughter]
he just dubs over kumquat
trisha i am so grateful that you took
the time to come and do this and hang
out with us and i want to know
where like i know we've got sad boy
music
sadboy 2005.com yeah a new drop coming
soon
yeah we have a we have another line
coming out september and then we have
like a store opening in november
where that's just me spending money it's
literally not gonna make any money
i'm just like wanting to have my own
store um it's in west lake village
it's like ventura county it's a little
absolutely yeah wait
i think it's more for me to just have
like meet greets and feel like esther's
gonna work there
just for merch for a discount yeah
yeah i really it'll be fun it's like
playboy merch it's kind of like that
kind of stuff the old school playboy i
love like girls next door so we have
like ours like a little bunny
yeah oh my god come to the store you
come to everything
you should give trisha some sleepover by
us i would love to i have a
lounge oh i love it i always see you for
morning i love it it's so cute yeah
i have one shirt i feel like a loser
yeah i drew this oh that's i was looking
at the whole time that's so cool
with both of you first both have merch
and i have
none of them have given me one item of
this is the only one i had to go to
whitney's house this is the sister of
the traveling shirt i have one of my own
shirts
and mine sold out
she learned from skims mine is held up
in the factory it's coming soon
okay i haven't there's literally someone
holding it because you asked for my size
i know and then there was a production
issue but it's being handled okay thank
you mister
and you also have trish you have your
own skincare
yeah trashcan.com that's in a
collaboration the ad for that
was so good i know the proactive
commercial or the
miracle elixir yes miracle i had two ads
i did one like just because i'm super
active and then i did the
and it was like a filter on it and it
was meant to be that way but like you
have a filter on your skin i'm like oh
it's supposed to be like two thousand
okay and then yeah the miracle elixir
which everyone's like it was piss and
sweeney todd and i was like oh i didn't
really
think about it i was just like oh it's
cute i can like sell my miracle yeah
it's uh it's just through a
small business here she actually helped
me clear up my acne and she goes do you
want to like help me like promote and i
was like yeah so then she kind of like
i'm like the face of it but she did it
all her name's uh charlotte with glow
skin enhancement she's here in the
valley and she's like really good with
like skincare it's like good products
people looked it up it's like
manufactured here it's shipped here it's
made here it's everything
wow that's incredible yeah it's really
good it's actually really good stuff
what else what am i missing because i
love
i love that you're you're the
entrepreneur what what am i missing
i think that's everything anything
coming anything you can hint
that that might be coming just the
weddings we're on a wedding tour this
year i think that's about it the wedding
some new positions in the morning at
night
some new positions yeah if you want to
see that it's only church.com
and your youtube channel your videos are
always so entertaining and i love that
i love when you eat and you review fast
food
original plan which we'll maybe do down
the road was to give you all of your
7-eleven favorites but then we saw that
you were on um a current um
a fitness journey and we didn't want to
derail you oh thank you
yeah i i just try and eat healthy like
two of the three meals a day or i try
and do like three of the
seven days of the week i train eating
healthy i think you say three of the
seven meals i was like yeah three meals
a day
like i haven't done three meals a day
for a long time no i i'm trying but i i
do eat like i still eat still
so yeah thank you so much
yeah thanks for watching i know we'll
see everybody next time
bye guys thank you
[Music]
you